to
.
Holy crap
Holy carps
Whoa, oh
My snippets my senpai, thank you so much for I
I went on and I looked I was like there's so many people here already with the hecky
Thank you
Everyone
For all
Thank you, thank you, thank you eat be a little bit, okay?
I'll tell you guys why I'm super eat be right now at first. I was gonna do a hand camp stream, but
Um
Yesterday if you saw my twitters, uh
You saw my Twitter I
Yeah, I got a pretty bad rash on my arm my dominant. What's what's worse is it's my dominant arm right now, and I've
But for a stream I've iced it for like one hour and
Basically, it's kind of like it's if it doesn't go away by
If it doesn't go away by by by by
Saturday, I'm gonna go to the doctor
What happened? I don't know it's just an allergic reaction. It just happens sometimes
Which one is your dominant hand my right so it's my right arm that's got
That got so it's like super. It's red. It's as red as like a lobster
It's as red as a lobster and really really itchy and
I accidentally scratched it and it started bleeding
So we're not gonna do that and so I'm going to spare my senpai's worry by not
Doing a hand camp stream
Yeah
Did you smear eggs all over your arm? I don't think so, but I might have touched something that had eggs on it
And then I just like flared up real bad
That just happens
That just happens like it was so red
It was so red like I was like oh dear. That's probably not good
Your allergy is that bad? I have to go to the hospital if it's super severe
especially
Especially if I ingest it
Anyways, so for today's stream instead
We're going to do things one-handed or at least it's possible to play with one hand and that is for today
For my membership. I am so happy to announce that memberships have opened as well as
As well as
As super chats and stuff. I think yes. Yes. Those are all open. Okay, but
Thank you so much senpai. It's always been my dream to
Make it this far as well. I have lots of goals and we're gonna we're gonna just just smash right through them. I
Think everyone can send super chest. I think yeah
Yeah, yeah, yeah
so um
I
Got a smash right through them. So today we are going to play a game. I
Might regret this I
Might regret this not seeing it available. Dang. Maybe it's just memberships only. Okay. I
Might regret this. Are you ready? I
Have tripled up on medication. I have senpai's gift to me for this
Anti-nausea bracelet thing that's sending electric waves and it kind of kind of feels funky. I have that I have ginger tea
Thank you, you know for with the 420 congratulations to our kohai Mercy truly lights up our lives here in this lovingly furnished
Basement greater than any celestial body can manage
Let her smile warm your soul and hey, it's a super chat
Um, oh, thank you for the congratulations rain. Uh, I have ginger tea. I
Took an anti-nausea pill and we are going to play don't scream
No, no, no, no, no, no
Now we're gonna add some caveats to this
We're gonna add some caveats to the don't scream for membership
If you gift to or more memberships, there is going to be a jump scare sound that will probably scare me
One memberships or if you just joined membership will also play a sound which might scare me if you donate or tip
$10 or more you can do text-to-speech, which will also scare the living bhajibra's out of me
So
And
So today
We're gonna see
How that works and I don't know why I I don't know why I'm freezing so much. Hold on. I think I know why hold on
Let me adjust some stuff. Okay. There there we go. There we go
Let me just tell you
Senpai I
Suck at horror. I hate jump scares
If I had flight or fight I would have fight and fight usually involves screaming
If
We're gonna try it out if by some chance I cannot do it
Please understand. Oh, thank you, Charlie
Charlie spur for the 10 Mary Seacal high. Can I leave the cage? I promise I won't run
I just want to stretch my legs, please. I promise. I love you. You can move to the bigger cage
If ice for some reason cannot do it
Please understand that. Oh my gosh. What the heck is this bracelet even? Is this sending me like shock shocks? What the heck?
You're ears probably won't die due to how I set up the microphone, but
If I cannot do it and I end up barfing, please understand. Oh
My gosh
I haven't started yet, I haven't started yet Senpai. Thank you
Thank you so much for your generosity, but also I haven't started yet Senpai
I
Stop please
Thank you so much finish for 10 whoa
Okay
Well your motion sickness permits you to play the game
I am tripled up as I've said I've tripled up anti nausea pill this thinking this bracelet who I don't know
If it works ginger tea, we're gonna see if it works
And let me tell you I'm not looking forward to this
What about the glasses
I'll bring out the glasses right now. I don't know where I put my glasses. I
Don't remember. Oh wait, it might be in a drawer. No, so not there
Let me put on my anti-nauseous dorky glasses as well
I don't think they're gonna work Senpai. I don't think my dorky glasses are gonna work
The liquid evaporated
The liquid in the
The glasses evaporated
They're just dorky glasses now
Isn't it literally in clothes in clothes in the frame frame. Yeah, but it evaporated
It's like how you get the liquid pens and the liquid in the pens evaporated. Yeah, anyways
I'm scared so please be nice to me
Can I leave the cage? I promise I won't run. I just want to stretch my legs. Please sad face
Shit
This might scare me
I'm just gonna play all of them
I can't believe it's resetting
Oh no, oh no
Oh no, it's also is this too sensitive now wait, I should I should talk I should talk quietly
Okay, let's see
That might work
Yeah
Okay, never mind we're gonna do this to 70 we're gonna see if this works at 70. Oh, yeah, we're good
I think this is good enough 70% looks good enough
Okay, so we're gonna test this out
Maybe I should have made this a little a
Little a little less
Okay, we're all good
Okay, we're gonna test this out, okay
Okay, ready
Okay, the sensitivity is not high enough
See the sensitivity in here versus the game is way different. Oh
Perfect
We're perfect, we're perfect
Okay, Iki macho
Minasan
I go where'd I go some pie
Left left left this is the left
Oh
I'm not happy
I
Don't play this game
Have a little bit
I'm a little bitch, baby. I'm a little piss baby
This baby
Little piss this baby. Oh piss, baby. Go. Hi
Gonna piss and cry
Just wanted to say that being so nervous on you debut yet going through with it anyway
Was genuinely very brave of you not everybody would have done that you've worked really hard and people recognized that and you deserve to
Be proud of yourself
Senpai
Senpai, I don't want to be here
Senpai, I don't want to be here. I'm a little bitch, baby. I'm a little piss, baby. I'm gonna shut up. She's gonna cry
Senpai
I don't like horror. I don't like horror
I'm gonna do it
Senpai, Senpai, please
Senpai
I'm scared, Senpai. I'm so scared
I don't like surprises. The only surprises I like are like catch-up on and
Blind boxes, you know, like the fun surprises. This is not a fun surprise
Merry monetization, Mercy. Please don't die while playing this XT
Ah
I don't want to check up my left
I don't want to check my left
Kuuai, I can keep you safe. I just need you to undo these restraints and give me the scissors
Fucking Christ
I
Listen
Listen, if the scary one is me
That's different. If the scary thing is something I don't know, that's different
Hey, I'm not giving back the scissors, Senpai. Thank you, Charlie
But I don't want it. And then you honor my scotty
And then you draw the arrow for the dead gifted
I don't think
There's a light. There's a motherfucking light. Who the fuck is out here?
I don't, I don't think they're a friend
Ah, Mr. Coward, Mr. Coward
Oh
I thought I heard something and then screamed on instant
In the haunted woods straight-up jumps carrying it and by it haha well, let's just say my oh she
Oh
Okay, that looks like that looks like
It looks like a van camper a camper
Give me a second
Oh
Sorry, I'm coughing a lot Senpai, okay
I actually do feel a bit of nausea right now. I think that's why I'm coughing a lot more
Oh, I'm gonna sip some tea
Okay
Cat birds, cat birds are nice
Cat, cat thing is great
Senpai
Senpai is that you?
Jesus fucking Christ
Senpai
Okay
Senpai, Senpai, Senpai, you know what's not even great right now, Senpai
Senpai
I think either mama, mama mercy or papa mercy is upstairs right now and they drop something and it scared the living shit out of me
I didn't pick up
But it uh, it scared the living shit out of me
I
Papa mercy collab when no no no no collapse with my parents as much as I love them very much
Papa and mama mercy are the type of person to be like real name drop
Sorry breaking cafe real name drop. Are these your students? Hi, we're from blank blank city. Here's my phone number
Yeah, that totally acts I could train them for ages to tell them what to say and what not to say and the moment
I hit live they're gonna all forget it
So uh
I can always pre-record them. That's not that's fun though. I don't think
I
It's not as fun if it's not live I think because I think they would want to see everyone's reactions live except for yeah
By the way today's word of the day Kohai um
Oh
Effervescent today's word of the day is effervescent, which means airy or bubbly
Can you use it in a sentence can you use it in a sense sentence Senpai?
The effervescent today's word of the day is effervescent, which means airy or bubbly
Can you use it in a sentence can you use it in a sense sentence Senpai
The taste of soda makes you delighted
Now
Wait wait no one knew about the a lot of you don't know the word effervescent
Really
I was thinking about it today. I was I bought a drink called uh
Rose strawberry not rose a rose like actually flower rose and
I thought the taste was rather effervescent and so I thought to myself Wow, this would be a great word of the day
Imagine parents having good opsec as they go ham on posting hot takes under their real name on Facebook
Opsec is
Operational security
It's a flavor. Yeah
Optics, okay. Thank you
Anyways, I thought about it. I thought about it today, and I was like effervescent is a great word
It's a great word because I think that
That
I think that
I don't know it really struck me once when I had a fortune told to me and they're like to get good luck today
Apply her makeup effervescent Lee and at that time I was like, what the fuck do you mean by effervescent Lee?
How do I apply my makeup effervescent Lee?
It's been stuck since it's been stuck since
I
Was like what the fuck you mean like lightly like airy like my brush barely touching my face. Whoa
Okay
Oh
Yeah, I have no idea I don't know I just remember I just remember like getting that fortune and I was like
No, Amy, what do you mean?
The adverb means enthusiastically so I gotta go
Sorry, I'm yapping. I'm sorry. I'm yapping
It was gonna be like, I don't know if I'm gonna do more yapping streams. I
I ax I sorry I accidentally turned this into yapping stream. It's supposed to be me crying like a little bish. Okay
No, I'm not stalling but I am not wanting to click play
Oh
Come on Marcy every stream was a yapping stream you're not fooling anyone. You're right. You're right
My heart my heart my heart when I saw the tree for some reason my heart just like my heart
Just like jumped more when I saw the tree when I walked into the tree. I don't know why
my heart
Chicken
This
Yeah, there he shows no fear
No, no, no, I do have I do have some fears. I do have some fears. I do have some fears. It's just that
When I'm in the mood
When I when I'm in the mood
I
Scare I scare I scare
I don't think I don't think I think you're all right
I want to close my eyes
I
Senpai
Shut the fuck up you're scaring me
I
Just
I don't like this
Like you
I
Can't I see shit
So
Can it still
I
I'm calling you
You are just
You just an object
Not even a face. You're just a body. You're an object body. Senpai
Senpai
Sorry
I'm gonna throw up
Fuck you
I
Don't go
Damn it
I did good
Yeah, honestly when I started moving the cameras I was like
Oh
Jesus fucking great
Thank you senpai's give me a second when I was moving, okay when
When I was moving the um
The camera and sprinting a little bit I I did get a bit of motion sickness
So I definitely I don't know. I don't know. How can you find?
How can I find blue stuff because I only found the one blue thing
I could fucking do it
Under soot
I can do this senpai
Fuck this thing. Fuck this game. Fuck this game. You're all Jim scares. Fuck it. I'm ready for them. Fuck this fucking game
Fuck this fuck
Maybe not the maybe not that
Okay, there's a point of interest is that a plane a bird a plane is that a bird
Boo boo
Give me that
That fish
Treats
Oh
Why is that sign pointing
Why is that why is that sign pointing?
Out of way
I followed
Am I supposed to follow
Senpai do I do I do I follow this
No
Don't eat me. No. No, don't follow that
Okay, it's okay. Oh, she's like this
Go to this electric tower
Why do I have to follow
Oh
Treats always jumpscare, okay
I'm gonna follow
What what it's a sign the game
Is it a misdirection?
I
Kuu I I know how to get you through this game
Here's the scenario your senpai escaped from your house. He's hiding in the woods
He broke his leg jumping from your window. You need to track him down before he escapes for good
What's
Let's hunt senpai senpai you're here somewhere, right? You're a bitch, right? Just kidding. You're not a bitch at all. I love you so much
What the fuck is that firework
Oh, why is there firework doesn't know it. I have membership this game. No, I have membership
Is that why there's fireworks?
Jesus
There's a sign. Jesus fucking Christ. It's always that fucking deer
There's voices
Oh
Thank you
It's fun
Stop flashing the lights stop flashing the lights actually nothing's here. It's good
Am I going there on urgent
Oh
I don't know which way I'm going I thought I just like go past it past the car
You
Sense of direction
It's about
Oh
My shoulders feel like they're up to my ears
Is that a vending machine? It's a vending machine, don't you?
Thank you
I'm not a vending machine. Let's see if he comes here
Oh
You bitch
I can't see some fun. Is that okay? I can't see
I can't see
Jesus fucking
Shit
Oh
I know you
I know you, and you're evil ways. You're trying to steal my supplies.
Al.
Yes, it called me too.
Objectifying, woman. Objectify the woman.
Objectify the woman. Objectify the woman.
The woman.
It's just a tree trunk.
Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness. It's just trees.
Give me a layer. Give me a layer. Give me a layer.
The battery's gone. It's my battery.
Okay. I think it's okay.
Okay.
It's okay.
Don't flick me.
I don't remember.
It's just trees.
Okay.
It's okay. It's okay. It's okay.
It's okay.
Oh, I've got a trail.
I've got a...
a chin.
No, I stopped. No, batteries.
The fuck are these?
Shut up.
Get away from me.
Look.
Okay.
Lady, stay away from me.
Lady?
It's scary.
I don't like this.
I can't look at this.
Let's go this way.
She heard that.
Come on.
Evan, come on.
Let's do it.
Okay.
Come on.
Sort of a picture.
Is there a battery?
The pie is no battery.
No, that's instinct.
It's very odd.
That's instinct.
The sensitivity is very high.
Sensitivity is very high.
I am just...
I am just literally swallowing my screens right now.
Come on, wait.
Ten more seconds.
Come on, come on.
Okay.
What now?
Good job.
Done.
Wait, doesn't he just give me congratulations?
Wait. What? Is this it over? How come I am still playing? Wait, is this it over?
It's over. It's over. It's over. I did it. I did it. It's over.
Honestly, Senpai, I don't know if you heard it. I don't know if you heard it.
I don't know if you heard, but I slapped my leg a lot. I slapped the armchair a lot when I got really spooked.
The sensitivity is pretty high, I think. It was pretty high. I tested it before Scream.
The sensitivity was pretty high. I think Senpai saw when I screamed, and now I just followed my scream.
I don't know. The sensitivity in the game is a little weird. I felt like some parts I should have been peeking, but I guess it didn't.
I guess it didn't. There was a close one, but I managed it. I was so proud of Senpai. Senpai was so proud of me.
Oh, sorry. Charlie. Thank you for all the donations, Senpai.
Sorry, I couldn't respond to them because I tried not to scream.
Thank you so much. Also reluctantly saying 440.
Is it text-to-speech only when the game is up? Yeah, so that it can spook me, so that it can scare the living Pajeebers out of me.
And you know what? It did. It did. It did, and I was like...
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted Venus.
Like, let's see. I see you. Daddycorn, I see you bastard. Also, Kauai. You have to do it alone in your room with the door closed and the lights off.
Okay.
You have no idea. Sperdedly, throughout the stream. Papa. I could hear the spoon. Papa. I think it was Papa. Papa Mercy was using, and I was like...
Oh.
That was my motion sickness. It's okay, but when I started moving the camera, I was like, oh, okay.
Well, I'm feeling a bit dizzy and a sense of vertical, but not so much as like...
I don't feel like... I don't know. It seems like it was working.
I think... I think the bracelet worked. Like, I didn't throw up. I just felt... I felt nauseous, but I didn't throw up.
Are we getting shocks? I just turned it off, but it did shock me throughout, so I was like, okay. Okay. Focus.
I was kind of cheating. I was kind of cheating. So, I was like, when it shocks me, focus on that. Focus on that. Focus on that.
Oof. Okay, hold on. I put some like, conductive gel on so that it would work better. I'm not sure if it worked, but I think it did. I think it did.
I think it did. Oh, man. I did it.
Shocks from this... Well, it didn't feel like shocks. It's more like buzzing. I'm wearing this motion sickness anti-nausea watch bracelet, bracelet thing.
It's called Emitter. E-M-E-T-E-R-M.
It's for this. Heart rate monitor next time.
Honestly, I don't know what kind of heart rate monitor I need. I need to do some research for that.
You think it helped? I think so? I'm not sure. I mean, I didn't throw up, but we'll have to test this again, Senpai. We're going to have to test this again.
Mind you, I was tripling up on my motion sickness stuff, so I had my ginger tea.
There will be a next time. Of course there'll be a next time. Not for this. Not for this. Not for this, though.
There's history with me and Daddy Korn. We keep finding each other in different B-Tuber chats. It's like the fifth or sixth time we've found each other in LL.
True love?
Ginger tea helps with my motion sickness. Ginger in general helps with nausea.
Nausea and throw yuppie.
Are you traumatized, Kohai?
Yes? That was cheap. That was really cheap at the end. What the heck? At the end where they had another lady pull up. That was so cheap.
Man.
I show up at the cages. Senpai, I fool up.
I was so mad.
Oh my gosh, Johnny. Oh my gosh, I just woke up from a nap with a banging headache. Congrats, Mercy. We love you.
I love you too. Good.
I beat the game, I think. That was so cheap. That was so cheap. At the bottom, I was like...
But there was a lot of times where I swallowed my scream. I swallowed my scream. I only screamed once.
But I actually screamed many times. I think at odd times. I actually screamed, but I swallowed it.
Oh man, the sounds did not help. The sounds did not help.
The sounds did not help.
I eat to this. I eat to the end when...
The sounds were the scariest parts. Yes, I was so scared.
Hey, Johnny, did you know Mercy's gonna be swallowing? Swallowing my screams?
I remember he made chicken noises. That's because someone said, are you a chicken, Mercy?
And I said yes, and I started balking and clucking.
Can you use the 3DO next time? Ambient whimpering sounds?
But I thought birds weren't real.
Yeah, I got a glass of water and come back to swallowing. You guys can admit it. I hired good.
Marcherary assistance. Uh, scared yandere ASMR. I'm scared of other things.
But when I'm... I get tunnel vision, Senpai. I get tunnel vision.
I get really, really bad tunnel vision, so when I'm like really pissed, all I can see is red.
And that's how I, like, run.
I remember, um, I think Shibi said I'm hiding my power level from you guys, and I'm just like, oh, yeah, I'm a little bit, I'm a little bit hiding it.
I, with the power, I think it's funny, but like, I was like, Senpai, Senpai, please help me. Senpai, Senpai!
The 2D games be easier on your emotions like this? 2D games usually are, except for some games.
Um, some gay, okay, actress. Shut up. I'm not...
I know there's a lot of part where I'm acting, but I'm trying to be really, really kind to Senpais and not really go on Menhera.
You have no idea. I went, like, strongy had to be like, they're there, they're there, Mercy, they're there.
Because I'm trying not to be that bad.
Any chance we can get you to try some 2D horror games if they spook you less than 3D ones?
Will you go full Menhera one day? Um, I will probably...
I will probably let it slip.
I will probably let it slip one day. I really try my best to, to...
I know, I know people want to see it, but I'm trying my best to, to be...
to be...
Oh my gosh! Thank you, Sheldon Zero, for 50 gifts!
Holy, holy moly.
We love our Menhera, too, Bruce.
You have no idea. Before stream, um, well, I went out to, to, to, to, um, to get some ASMR stuff as well,
because I was like, okay, well, if, I'd like to do a, do a hand cam for my membership,
and then I was looking at my arm before stream, and I was like, I don't think I can do it.
I don't think I can do it, because my, my arm is so red.
My arm is so red. It's beyond...
It is, like, really, really, like, itchy and gross.
It's itchy, gross, uh...
Really bumpy as well, so, and, like, kind of looks, kind of, and, like, looks really bad,
so it's not flaky, but it's, like, bumpy, bumpy everywhere, and, like, super red,
so I, I was worried that if I did, if I did a hand cam stream,
that some pies would be worried with it.
It can't be, it's like, it was, like, bleeding, too, so I was worried that, uh...
Do you need to see a doctor for it?
I'm going to see if it goes away by Saturday, and if it doesn't go away by Saturday.
Um...
It's... I'm going to go to the doctor.
Bleeding, it's because it started to, um...
I scratched it a little bit, and then it got caught, I guess.
So I, the entire stream, I'm wearing this, uh...
This compass, this, like, arm, arm compass thing, and as well as, uh...
You're going to wrap your arms in bandages just like your model has?
I didn't have time to go out and buy bandages, and also, um...
I was worried because the compress didn't work for a while,
that it would become more inflamed, inflamed, uh...
if it was stuck under bandages and due to the friction, so I, um...
put it, put on a lot of ice, like, a lot of, uh, ice,
and you can feel, if I was here, um, if Senpai was here, you can touch my arm,
and you can feel, like, really, like, heat radiating out of it.
I think it's just an allergy thing. I don't think it's eczema.
It's a, it's a, it's a allergy thing. I probably touched...
touched, um, touched egg or something.
But, yeah, that's why I was, I opted for not to do a hand cam,
but I'll, I'll make it up. I'll make it up to Senpai.
Gloves? Uh, I'm wearing an arm sleeve right now that has, like, gloves.
Did you accidentally ingest an egg product?
No, I think this is, uh, if I ingested, it would be a completely different reaction,
and I wouldn't be able to breathe.
Uh, this one is touching. I'm pretty sure it's just touching.
Hold on, are you allergic to latex?
I don't have it.
I don't have any latex on my bed, so when I woke up, it was on my bed, so...
or, like, something I bumped into earlier in the day.
I, I, last night, I showered because it was, like, really bad,
and I'm probably gonna have to ice it after stream again.
Bed bugs? No.
If it was bed bugs, it would look like bug bites.
This is definitely, like, hive slash rash.
It was a shower lesson link. I had it before the shower.
I wanted to make sure that it was washed.
Whatever residue was on my arm was washed off as well.
Um, it was washed off, and it's just...
This happens sometimes. It rarely happens to me, but...
it happens.
It, it doesn't happen often, but this sometimes happens.
Sometimes it just pops out of nowhere.
Honestly, it's, I've seen this happen before,
and it usually takes a few days to, to clear up,
but unfortunately, Senpai, um...
it just happened to have appeared yesterday,
and just, and all the way to today,
which is really, really sad.
I took some Benadryl, too, and when I took Benadryl,
the inflammation went down a little bit as well.
I put on, like, uh...
some lotion as well, so it's good.
Did it start as a little weird little bump skull hive?
It started out, like, basically kind of like this, like a rash.
Could it be from stress?
It could be stress. It's just on, it's on my, um...
it's just on my right arm, which is unfortunate,
because it's my, as this happened before, I think so.
I think it's happened before.
The universe just didn't want to see a hand cam.
It happens. Oh!
One time, Senpai's.
This is really funny.
Um...
One time, I was gonna play League.
I was gonna try to play League.
So the day I set up a whole thing about, like, uh...
League,
and then my body rejected League.
It rejected it.
I got sick for three months so badly.
Like, the day...
the day I was going to play League for the first time,
I got so terribly ill.
Three months, yeah.
Uh, I don't know what happened, really.
I took a test for COVID,
and it went out negative,
but I also had symptoms of asthma, asthma symptoms,
and I was throwing up a lot, like, a lot,
and I got a lot...
I got intermittent fevers, and it lasted for, like, three months.
I was like...
I was like, oh, my God!
The world just...
My immune system just did not want me to play League.
I blame League because it was the day,
the day I was gonna play League that it happened.
Like, I'm so toxic.
I...
I'm so glad I'm not sick like that anymore
because, um,
I actually lost my voice for the first time.
I don't know why.
I don't know why that happened.
I just thought it was really funny,
so I took that as a sign not to play League.
I took that as a sign not to play League
because, um...
I actually lost my voice for a little bit, too,
so I...
So, people just can...
just hear, like,
step by step by.
Ha ha ha!
That was such a huge coincidence.
It was such a...
a major coincidence.
Maybe the arm rash is a reaction to another game.
I just... I'm taking this as a...
I'm taking this as a sign
to... to get...
to wait a little bit
to do, like, a hand cam or something for some pies.
I don't know why.
The universe is a little silly thing.
Honestly, um, I felt really bad
because I had planned all around, like, a hand cam and everything,
but, uh, I think this was okay, too. This was okay.
Thank you so much for joining me on my membership opening day, as well.
I'm so happy.
Because, like, I want to be at my best health for some pies
to do a, um...
to do a hand cam.
And if... and I really think
some pies would just really...
really, uh...
really...
hate how...
and be, like, super worried about how red and bumpy it is.
Like, you can even see the bumps through the... the sleeve.
The, like, a little compression sleeve.
Any other plans for membership stuff you can tell us about?
I'm actually still in the middle of planning some membership stuff.
Because, um, I've never had membership before, so...
and I've never membered to anyone before.
So I'm gonna see...
and I'm gonna see if Strawny...
Strawny will, like, um...
help as well. Help out with things.
Ah! Azura!
I can't leave you... leave you yet.
Some pies don't want... doesn't want me to leave.
What do you need, uh, Strawny?
It's like, oh, I was hoping Strawny could help me with, like...
Strawny, I meant to be, like, uh...
I was hoping you can... you can help me with...
think of, like, membership stream ideas.
Oh, my gosh!
Azura!
What am I even doing?
Oh, my gosh!
Serenity!
What the heck?
Thank you! Thank you, everyone!
Thank you, everyone, for the raid!
Thank you!
Sweetie puns and Azura!
It's bleeding hard!
Up!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
John Zero, thank- Whoa!
Whoa!
Thank you for 50! 50!
50, 50, 50, 50.
Yep, did what the hecky-wecky.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, my golly, gee, will occurs as...
as, uh... as Serenity would say.
Oh my gosh, thank you! Everyone has been so kind and generous, thank you!
Hahahahaha!
Thank you so much, I'm so happy.
Hahahahaha! That's singing earlier, Mariah Mercy.
Hahahahaha!
I'm not, I'm actually pretty excited but also pretty nervous about the karaoke stream
because I'm gonna be singing in front of so many people and I'm not even gonna,
I'm not gonna, I'm not even gonna, I think I'll just get a little bit of stage fright.
I think I'm gonna get a bit of stage fright.
Hahahahaha!
Honestly, honestly, I'm so thankful everyone, I'm so thankful, I'm honestly super, super thankful.
Yeah, wait to hear you sing, I'm sure you do so well, thank you Azura! I don't think I'm as good,
I think I'm pretty average, like not terrible but not amazing, but I'm practicing,
I'm practicing. I want to be the Arrow Idol you, you can love and enjoy.
I really,
guys she's being humble, her singing is cute, no, no, no, I'm honest, I'm honest to gosh.
I'm really hyped to see my song choices, you, my song choices, probably not the greatest.
Oh my goodness! Thank you Lily Lycodes for 20, what the, no, oh, oh, I don't know how to,
I'm not going to lie, I'm not going to lie senpai's, I am flabbergasted, flabbergasted
about all these, all these gifted, gifted member memes, memes, memes? I was gonna say subs because
brain rot but gifted members, membership.
I am, honestly I am so glad to be here, to be part of VLR, I know that it might be frustrating
that I, I'm a very slow person but this is, this is like the first time I've had so many eyes on me.
You know, this is the first time I've had so many eyes on me and so many kind people,
just be, just be super, super, super nice. I hope, can I, can I get sappy a little bit, can I get sappy?
Um, sappy, everyone? Like I feel so welcome at VLR, I get, I was so excited to meet you senpai,
like honestly, honestly, I'm so, so excited to meet my senpais, like I'm, okay, I'm gonna
just admit it, I do stalk, I do stalk my senpais, wait a bit. Now that Twitter likes are turned off,
I can't, I can't, it's harder to stalk you.
But sometimes I go, if you're on Twitter or something, I go into and I'll be like, oh you
have two cats, what's your cat's name? What are you into? Oh, you'll, you live in, I don't know,
so-and-so place, how interesting, how interesting, oh your weather there is like this, how interesting,
you have a sister, how interesting.
Oh my goodness, thank you, default for 10 as well, oh my goodness.
Don't worry, I, I notice, I notice all my senpais.
I, I try to hide the minhara a little bit
because I feel like it's, sometimes I just want to make you happy, I just want to make you happy
and I don't want to, to pull you down by, by being super minhara.
Don't hide it from me please.
Yeah, I mean like, I, I try my best to show my best, my best face here, behind closed doors, I,
I'm, I'm not, I'm very much a little bit of a, of a creep.
I know minhara is part of the experience, but I don't know, I think I feel like having
a minhara breakdown in front of everyone is just not great, so I do it, off stream.
Like, oh my gosh, I, I branded and like cried to my, to my gen,
gen mates because of just how, how meadow, meadow illinois.
I am.
You look like the most sane member of VLOR so far.
You guys like higurashi?
Think about re, rena.
Okay, you know how she's kind of sweet at the beginning?
And then the itch happens.
And then everything goes to heck.
Um, right now I'm in the, that, that, the, the early parts.
I'm like at the early parts where she's very kind and she's very, you know, loving.
I'm at that part right now.
I'm at that part right now, like I've,
I'm at that part right now, so I'm trying my best to hold it back.
No, no, no, no, I, I really mean it.
I'm, I'm holding myself back, honestly, honestly, honestly.
Honestly, I'm trying to hold myself back simply because I really, I really, I really want
to be at my best and, and senpais.
I know, I know you're like, oh my gosh, let's make her worse.
Menhera, she's going to be so great when she has that Menhera breakdown.
It's going to be, I don't think so.
I think when you see that Menhera breakdown, you're going to just be worried.
You're just going to be worried.
You're going to be concerned and worried.
So yeah, I, I want to be me and the me that I want to be is,
it might slip, it might slip, but most of the time please understand
I will be in dairy mode.
I will be in dairy mode
because I am so in love.
I'm so in love.
Legitimately, I will stalk you.
I, I'm not going to say, I'm not going to say, actually, you know what?
Secret, this is a secret.
This is a secret.
Yeah, I, the Menhera will come out.
Don't worry.
You, you don't like secrets?
Nah, no.
I want to keep senpais on their toes.
I'll keep senpais on their toes.
You can't keep secrets from senpais.
What if it's a surprise?
It's a surprise.
You already cut off all my toes?
I'll keep you on your heels.
Only if we get to stalk you back?
No, stalking is a one-way street and it's my street.
Senpais, please understand, it is mine, mine, and mine alone.
Okay.
No, seriously.
Why, senpai, senpais, settle down, settle down, senpai, settle down.
Settle down, senpai.
You're okay.
The surprise is for you to wait for.
Okay.
Why do you cut another girl stalking us?
Maybe both of you need to go.
Settle down, that's it.
What's in the syringe, Kohai?
Don't worry, it's a surprise.
Mmm, I want senpais to see all facets of me, but for now, please have this.
Please view me as your adorable Kohai, okay?
And always remember that I am so, so, so understanding and that you are my,
you are mine.
When you speak like this, I can't refuse.
I feel like that's like a serious voice.
I feel like if I, if I want to capture your attention, I have to, I have to,
I have to talk in my serious voice.
My serious voice.
Just like Nyan Tataro said.
Let's check out my schedule.
I'm so very thankful.
Oh, right.
I didn't, I was, I went off track.
I went off track, senpai.
I went off track.
I was about to say, I was going to say Nyan Tataro coming back soon, probably not.
How many more voices, how many voices do you have?
It depends on the situation, what kind of voice I use.
Like my phone voice is, hello?
Hello, yes?
I'm calling about my internet service provider.
My provider?
Yeah, my internet is down right now.
Can I?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
Thank you.
Yeah, that's no problem at all.
Yes, yes, yes.
That's fine.
Yes, that's fine, yes.
Please, yes, I need my internet.
I need my internet.
It's very important that I hire internet as soon as possible.
Yes, I understand, I understand.
But please, can I have some?
I'm only being provided four, four up and four down
when it should be at least 50.
That is like the phone voice.
It depends.
Or if I'm talking to someone, I, like, you know,
like maybe someone like a, like a, like my doctor, I'm like, yeah.
So I've been feeling a bit of stomach issues.
And, and I have some throat issues.
Is there anything that we can do to alleviate it?
And then, then you know, your stage voice.
Welcome, everyone.
Welcome, welcome to Mercy Modi's show.
Today we will provide you with an excellent service with,
I don't know, catering and blah, blah, blah, you know, things like that.
Everyone has a different voice for a different situation.
And it happens that when I get a little serious
or I want you to calm down or pay attention,
it's like, listen here, okay.
Okay, listen up.
But they're all facets of me.
Therefore, all facets of me.
They're all facets of different versions of,
of when, you know, you, you want to command a different sort of attention
depending on the voices.
So for example, you know, if you're like talking to a kid,
it's completely different, right?
You're like, oh, sweetie, are you lost?
Where's your mommy?
You know, something like that.
Something like that.
Compared to when you talk to an adult, right?
Or if you talk to your dog or your pet, aren't you so cute?
Come here, come here now.
Come here, come here.
Good boy, good boy.
I think, I think that's, when you say I have different voices,
it's still all me.
Just a different, I pick a different type of voice to use all the time.
Yeah, my real voice is this though.
I feel like, how many members do I have?
I don't know.
How can I tell?
I don't know how to tell some pie.
Oh, right.
I didn't know you had a mommy voice.
I don't want to steal Azra's part, but I guess the mommy voice would be like,
I guess if I had to do a mommy voice, actually, it would probably be like,
What's up, Eve?
Do you want a piece?
You want a piece?
Okay, okay.
Are you ready?
Hold on, let me move the microphone to make this sound realistic.
There you go.
Look how high you are.
You're so great.
Whoosh, and back down again.
Something like that.
I don't want to, I don't want to, that's Azra's thing.
That's Azra's thing.
So if you want like the mommy experience, that's Azra.
But I can do like the occasional,
um, mommy-ish voice.
Sounds like a more like a babysitter.
I failed.
See, this is why Azra's the master.
This is why Azra's the master at being the motherly,
motherly figure, and I am just mercy.
Melfi Henry ASMR when honey.
Wait, no, no.
Hold on.
Sweetie, you're kind of catching cold.
Wear this.
Wait, is that a lipstick mark?
Who the fuck was this from?
Damn, I sound like an aunt instead of a mommy.
This is rude.
I sound like an aunt.
Oh my gosh, I failed.
I failed at my attempting a mommy voice.
That's fine.
It's not, it's not who I was meant to be.
It's not what I was meant to do.
The voice you did in the trailer
sounds like a completely different person.
I think when I recorded it, I think that's just how the editor did it.
I think that's just how the editor did it.
What better way?
I don't know.
I don't remember my lines.
Fear is a top shelf ad-redeasy.
I don't know.
Did it sound like that?
Maybe I did a voice by accident.
I get nervous.
I get nervous and I'm just like, okay, okay, I'll do the voice.
I was probably also not as cheerful and probably was like, oh my gosh, I'm extra nervous.
Mercy is an auntie.
Technically, I would be called an aunt and like,
depending on like family relation stuff.
Even if they're older than me.
I can't believe I sound like an aunt instead of mom.
See, this is why.
This is why.
This is why I can't do it.
If you were nervous, you didn't sound nervous.
I was probably more nervous.
When I'm nervous, I guess, I don't know.
I don't know what happens.
My brain just turns off and just goes, go.
If you collab with Azura, I could play the aunt role.
I'm not just a regular aunt.
I'm a cool aunt.
You have no idea, Senpai.
When I'm, I used to be so nervous that I would just like,
I would be like shaking.
But I guess I was still kind of nervous then too.
Yeah, I feel like I disappointed people.
I feel like I disappointed people.
But Senpai's when, when I, when those audios released.
I feel like I disappointed Senpai's.
And then Senpai's came here and then they heard this.
And they're like, she sucks.
I hate her.
Throw hammers at her.
Let's kill her with hammers.
What, no?
Oh, I meant like, I feel like I disappointed everyone
because it's not, it's not like, that's not regular.
That's not like my regular voice.
This isn't my wheel.
My wheel.
Don't be so hard on yourself.
It's a little hard.
I'm, I definitely feel like it's still a dream that I'm here.
I guess.
It still feels like a dream that I'm here.
I'm very happy to be here.
I'm so happy to be here.
I, it's the most fun I've had in a long time.
I feel like the scenario, oh, speaking of,
did anyone listen to the Patreon audio?
I think I just want to say that I think the current Patreon audio
is the one, it's my very first one I recorded.
It's the very first one I recorded.
So I was definitely very nervous for that one.
I was very nervous for that one.
And when I did that one, after I, I sent it, sent it to,
to management to be like, okay, here you go.
I was like, I, this is so fun.
This is so fun.
I love this so much.
I honestly was like, oh, this is such great fun.
I'm, I love this.
I'm so happy that, that I can do this on the regular.
And I was just like, that was when I was like, yeah,
I belong in Bealer.
I do, I do.
But then I question it sometimes, because that,
then you have imposter syndrome, right?
But then it's in waivers and shakes a little.
But no, I'm glad.
Oh, shit.
I meant to tell you the story of like, like being a little sappy.
I'm, thank you.
I'm so thankful that I have monetization and that I could,
there's a possibility I could do this full time,
because I want to tell some pies.
I want to tell some pies.
I know this sounds, this may sound weird and stuff,
but
Papa, before, before, before I was born,
before I was born,
Papa Mercy used to live outside of a car, out of a cardboard box.
And so, and for Christmas and stuff,
Christmas is and stuff, I would have a,
I would have,
yeah, before he came, he came here, he used to live in a cardboard box
and he made his way up.
And then most of my life we were still not a, not quite in, in like a very,
very good, good situation.
So growing up, it was, it was like, gifts were like donation gifts and stuff,
and clothes were, were donated, or donated, and
so being able to be here, be here, have, having,
spending money, a bit of spending money, and
making my way, using, working my, working my butt off to buy this,
this streaming setup and stuff.
I'm so glad it paid off.
I'm so, so, so glad it paid off, and that my dreams have come true,
and that, that I got to meet my senpais, and I'm so, so, so happy,
so happy.
I'm so happy
that I'm here.
So thank you so much for all the generosity and all the kindness,
senpais have shown me, I truly, truly, truly, truly appreciate it.
Like honestly,
can you, can I write equipments off in taxes?
These are over, like, these are years, years old.
These are years old.
So I'm glad that I can actually put them to full, full, full use,
full use for my senpais.
I'm so happy.
Thank you.
Thank you for the dollar, Logan.
Ago, you're all worth all this, and way, way more mercy.
I wish we had the resources to give you what you actually deserve.
It's okay senpai, it's okay, it's okay.
Being here, and being, you know, being here, and talking,
and entertaining everyone is our, is my favorite thing to do.
Honestly, and when I get off stream, sometimes I go, I miss them.
What's your type of senpai if you don't mind me asking?
Kind?
My favorite senpai is someone who is kind.
And I think that applies to all of you.
Ellen Meij, her favorite senpai is a slow runner.
Well, I can't seem to argue that either.
I can't argue that either.
Oops, you caught me.
Kind, loyal, and won't run, right.
Okay, correct.
Thank you for the 420.
Congratulations on monetization.
You're literally the only Meiju I've ever seen play Harvester.
Stay based, hope to see you play more obscure indie slash old plot
heavy games.
You're the best go-high ever.
Thank you, Nick Foggy.
How do I say this?
I don't think Harvester is very obscure.
I think Harvester is quite well known.
I just don't think a lot of VTubers play point and clicks.
I just don't think they play a lot of point and clicks.
I've never heard of it until you played it.
Man, maybe I'm...
I think maybe it's because I knew the history of it.
I thought I thought that I...
I think maybe that I was...
I thought that, perhaps.
Me, I do Azarel also play point and clicks.
Nice, nice actually.
Maybe it's because I knew the history about it that I was like,
oh yeah, it's a common game.
Is it very meiju?
Can you guys tell that my sense of what's popular and what's not
is severely skewed?
It's severely skewed?
Point and click brain round.
Honestly, honestly.
Every time like, oh yeah, people are like,
oh, have you played this really niche game called...
I have no mouth and I must scream and I'm like, oh yeah.
Isn't it popular though?
Isn't it like, didn't it win awards and stuff?
Like Harvester, I feel like everyone kind of knew it.
Thank you for the $3.33,
how do I become your favorite senpai?
I don't play favoritisms.
I don't play favoritism except, you know, like the girlies, the like...
Like, if Serenity says she's like a senpai then like,
technically she has rights and like the Yume plus girls, they have...
They work to dig the...
They also do some work to dig the holes outside to hide the bodies.
So they get a little bit more but I let my...
I let my...
Yeah, content creator rights.
They have a little bit more things but like honestly,
if you told me who would I choose Serenity or Senpai, I would choose Senpai.
I'm sorry Serenity, I...
I'm sorry but you get it, right?
You get it.
But like Serenity is a pretty close second.
That's surprising.
You have no idea how much joy Senpai, you give me, honestly.
You have no idea how much joy you all give me.
And if you weren't my number one,
why would I try to try so hard to keep you here, you know?
On a scale of one to ten of joy, one million, one million, three billion!
You just have to stay on course, okay?
You just have to stay on course.
If Senpai steps out of line from my fairy tale, I might get a little mad.
But overall, I do love you very, very, very, very much.
It's not a bit, it's not an act, I truly do.
Because without you, I wouldn't be able to have so much fun.
And every day is like a date.
And I'm always, I always go to bed thinking about my Senpais.
And I always go to bed and I wake up in the morning going,
I want to hang out with Senpai.
I won't stalk Senpai too much.
As long as Senpai doesn't look into me too much either.
Okay, I won't show up at Senpai's house unannounced, unless...
You know what, actually, no, I get that right, never mind.
I get that right, you do not.
Why? Because you're stuck in the cage!
But like, I don't want, I don't, I really, my boundaries is that I just don't want to like,
I literally do not want Mama and Papa Mercy to get involved.
Because I would be pissed.
And like, I, as I said, back, back a while ago, I do, I did have quite the violent tendency.
And it might come out again.
It might come out of the end.
Which is why...
Which is why I got a lot of maros saying like, what did you mean by like, don't get overly attached?
I mean, I meant like, don't get my family involved, don't like,
don't like, you know, bother my family or my friends about that.
Because I, I will get pissed, I will get pissed.
And probably like, you will see more of the Yan and not any of the Dairy part.
Like, I thought, I thought, I thought the way, I realized the way I worded it is weird.
But I meant, I meant it as like, don't get too attached as in like, you call my parents and
my, my IRL friends have to lock their doors or something because I will...
I don't think there would be another Senpai.
I don't think there will be a Senpai because I'm very protective.
I'm very protective of them.
And I think I would get pissed, I would get pissed.
I think I legitimately would get pissed because that is not a part of my fairy tale.
That is not a part of my fairy tale happy ending.
You would mess with your family?
I don't know.
It's, I don't know.
But there was a lot of times where I had to get involved because
I, I am protective of my family.
Like for example, someone, okay, this is a long time ago, so don't worry.
Don't worry, someone assaulted my
Papa Mercy, my father, and I was so fucking pissed.
I was about to get over there with like a knife and just go at it.
Just like go crazy.
So I'm very protective of them.
I'm beyond protective of them.
So, yeah.
Like I was, I was, I was mad.
I was mad.
You mean like a stranger physically attacked him like in a parking lot?
A neighbor, a neighbor did.
And a neighbor did and the cops are called and I was about to like
break down that neighbor's door.
I moved, luckily, but I was about to break down that neighbor's door.
The one who stole his presents?
No, no, no.
That's a different neighbor.
Different neighbor.
I, the police did get involved and luckily, so I calmed down quite a bit, but I was,
I was mad.
And honestly, sometimes some senpais get me really mad too.
Like some senpais get me really pissed.
I don't know if those are real senpais or like fake senpais, but some senpais make me really pissed.
Because like sometimes I feel like my boundaries are
like probably fake senpais, but sometimes, like sometimes my boundaries are like they say mean
things and I'm just like pissed.
Make sure to say something if we make you pissed.
You know, you know, you know, if I'm pissed.
You know, if I'm pissed, there will be a few signs to know that I'm pissed.
It's not me, right?
No, no, no, I'm, I've been, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Like I think you'll know when I get pissed because there's some obvious signs.
The first sign of being annoyed is if I go, if I start talking like this,
it means I'm really fucking annoyed.
And that's when senpais need to settle down a little.
And then I get really pissed.
I will call mods.
You know, you know, if I'm pissed, I will call the mods.
But no, no, no, sometimes I get pissed on messages when I see certain messages.
Yeah, if you're, they're trying to push boundaries and stuff.
Most likely fake senpais, yeah.
I even hesitate to call them senpais because then I'm just like,
are they a pretender?
Are they a faker?
Are they not in the cage?
I apologize in advance.
Don't worry.
Water off a duck's back.
I can forgive pretty easily, except for certain things.
Except for certain things.
Then I don't forgive at all, ever.
Boundaries how?
Things that I don't like crossed, for example, would be like.
Let's give, let's give a fairly light example that I don't like.
My fairly light example that I don't like is a backhanded compliment.
Another thing that's like, oh my God.
Pam!
B-C-O-L of Play Asia.
Congrats upon attization.
Thank you, Pam.
Thank you.
Thank you, Raiders.
Hello, welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
This is my monetization stream, and we just finished play.
No, just wait.
How long have I been yapping for?
Oh, I don't know.
Anyways, I did play.
I did play Don't Scream, and I was screaming internally so hard.
I was like.
But like more like.
Boundaries talking to her.
Forget it.
Forget about it.
Was I talking for 40 minutes?
Why does chat need to know how to push your buttons?
Are you sure that's a good idea?
You're right.
I'm going to shut the fuck up now.
You know what?
Silence!
You're right.
I'm going to shut the fuck up.
See, I get loose-lipped when I'm around Senpai,
because I feel so comfortable around Senpai.
See, this is why we have secrets between us.
We have secrets between us because it can be leaked, okay?
Sometimes there are fake Senpais amongst us.
They're rude.
I must be cold.
Oh, thank you.
You suck at best.
Even though you can't sit the zap too,
we always ended up getting it anyways.
No, I don't want secrets.
It's secrets.
Respect them.
I don't know all about Kawaii.
But Senpai made a good point saying that you could use it against me.
And you know what?
That's fair.
So therefore, tight-lipped, I be.
Mercy, you've been talking for over an hour.
I really should stop talking.
Honestly, I really should stop talking.
Which lips?
The one on my face.
Ah!
Let's be real.
If you were playing on Maury, it would be longer.
Nah, I feel like I shouldn't.
I shouldn't, yeah.
Because I feel like a lot of people take
what I say, when I yap, out of context.
And I'm just like...
I'm not very articulate with words.
I'm not good with words.
So I feel like I shouldn't yap as much.
I shouldn't yap.
I shouldn't yap so much because I always get marbles.
Marbles by the end going,
what did you mean by this?
What did you mean by this knife?
I'm like...
I shouldn't yap.
I should stop yapping.
I will yap if you promise not to take everything I say into a cruel position.
Because I get marbles and I'm like...
I shouldn't even be telling you this.
This is how loose-lipped I am.
See, this is why I shouldn't yap.
Because then I tell you things that I wasn't planning to tell you.
Man, I...
Man!
Is it this rash talking or is it me?
It's probably the, yeah, the rash talking.
And I am...
Man.
It's the evil rash.
It's making me say things.
Make sticky notes to remind you of things not to say.
Man!
My yandere can't help but overshare.
I love how trusting she is before she ends me.
Oh my gosh.
I know.
I feel so comfortable around Senpai.
And then I'm like...
No, now Senpai's in order for you to keep the secret forever.
It's over.
I overshare a lot.
That's a bad habit of mine.
Are you going to take our away our tongues?
Yoink!
No, no flavors.
No tests.
No taste tests.
It's just gone.
You should avoid doxing yourself.
I'm very careful about that.
I have no tongue and I must scream.
That would be a fun parody game.
But then again, it's kind of like a silly game itself.
I have no mouth and I must scream.
Overshare.
No, I'm so bad.
Everyone.
Senpais, please look.
Please look.
Right here.
I learned this from Strawny.
Ready?
Right here.
OK.
Begetty beam.
So how's the games and pie?
I did a good job at hiding my screams right?
Congratulations monetization! Yes, yes, yes!
The game was great, yeah!
How many members are you up to? I don't actually know how to check that senpai!
I don't know how to check that senpai!
Thought it would take longer for you to to beat.
Screaming internally! I have learned a new trick today was that I can scream internally.
I just noticed you have emotes mercy! Yeah, do you like them?
Strawny picked them out.
At least one, I think I have at least one meh, one member.
Oh, speaking of, I finally relaxed! I finally relaxed a little bit yesterday.
Yesterday, so I could have my first day off, although I did work put a little bit on my day off.
It's my day off from streaming, not day off from working and at violor.
I found, I found, I found some fun, but I found one white hair!
I found one white hair! Oh my gosh! I was like, oh, I went, I guess, I guess I was really stressed, huh?
Hahaha!
Your schedule still make a pack! That was my mistake!
The week after is only three streams! I double checked! I triple, triple, triple checked!
I triple checked, I quad triple checked, made sure I have only three streams next week!
The one, the one white hair! Probably since debut prep! I was like,
ahhh! You know who found it? You know how, who found it? I was sitting down and then
Mama Mercy looked over and she's like, sweetie, you have a white hair! And I was like, ahhh!
Actually, it's, apparently that happens to me quite a bit. I mean, like, when I was in high school,
I had a white hair, but that doesn't make sense! Like, one white hair was like, completely white!
I was like, oh, if I'm under great duress, it's, it turns, one, one strand turns completely white!
With a little bit of like,
real talk, those can just happen regularly because of circumstances due to cellular,
cellular irregularities. I have one pale white beard hair every other time I shave.
What? You can't call me a hag just from one, you can't call me a hag just from one, one white hair!
You can't just call me a hag from that.
I just, I'm just saying that I had one because I feel like I probably overworked myself, yeah.
We love hags! Honestly, when someone called me a hag for the first time, I was like, what?!
I was so upset, and I went to look it up, and then I, and all of it was still in salt,
so I was too upset, and then someone had to tell me, no, no, no, hag means, it's, it's a good thing,
and I was like, I don't believe you, and then, and then, and then, and then I found out, yeah,
it's a good thing.
I found out it was a good thing. I, I was upset at first though, I was like,
how dare you?
Slaying is hard! I'm, I'm having trouble keeping up some like, some, some sayings and stuff.
Slaying is hard. I just can't keep up anymore. Take me back to the days when like, the big,
trendy word of the day was epic. That was so epic. Wow. Epic story, man.
Yolo. Leet.
Like a boss. Oh my gosh, yeah.
Hell.
Booper was hot for a hot minute, was it? Oh my gosh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, O'Reilly? O'Reilly?
O'Reilly?
What else did they have? Oh, and memes back there were like, back then was like, oh shoot,
what was the first one I saw? The philosopher? I think the philosopher was, was, was the memes
where they had it on like the kind of like, alternating, not the alternating like, I don't know,
background with the impact font on top and impact font at the bottom.
Oh, oh, oh, I made you a cookie, but I ate it.
Or, or the, uh,
what is it? The actor, what's his face from?
The Willy Wonka man leaning on, on the, on, on a hand going saying something that's like,
I don't remember that one.
Uh, Gene Wilder? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Where his leaning is like, oh, tell me about this, blah, blah, blah.
These are ancient. I'm trying to think of like,
sums that I can barely remember them.
Ra, Ra means I love you in dinosaur.
Yeah, the ones that saw condescending. Yeah, I can barely remember them.
What's that angry wolf one? I remember seeing that sometimes.
Good guy, Greg. Yeah.
Can I has cheese bugger insanity wolf? Really?
What's it called insanity wolf? It's the wolf one.
Chuck Norris. All right. I remember Chuck Norris. Everyone kept on doing Chuck Norris stuff.
You should do an old meme tier list. Can I even remember old memes?
Memes go by so fast nowadays. I can't keep up with them.
Chuck Norris can count your infinity twice.
I don't remember a lot of these. These are like,
these are like the ones where I'm like, huh.
I wonder.
Isn't Doge kind of new though? Is this kind of new? Maybe I'm out of, I'm out, I'm not much.
I'm out of time.
Doge is like a decade old.
Man, time is a construct.
I'm probably too much of a zoomer to know about hamster dance and dancing, baby.
Things I can barely remember.
I also remember.
She's gen X is over. Stop. Stop. Stop. Okay. Listen. Listen, guys. Listen, guys.
Listen, senpai.
I feel like, I feel like some of you have put me into age brackets and I'm just like,
I don't know if you will. I don't know. I don't know.
Into age brackets and I don't think they're entirely correct.
Don't let me in. Okay. Some senpais, some senpais have put me into age brackets
and I don't think they're entirely correct.
I feel like I've given many hints to the age range and I feel like all of it is being missed.
You remember meeting Julius Caesar? What do you mean? I'm him.
I'm him.
I'm skibbity straight
bussin. What else did I say?
God damn.
Zam.
She.
She. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Rizzler.
I can't catch up nowadays. I can't catch up nowadays.
Give me days. Give me damn. I don't know.
How's your back doing? It's fine. My back is fine.
I don't remember. I remember finally being taught like a lot of slang and I just kept on using them
and then my friends were like, I have no idea what you're talking about.
And then and then the new things are different.
For real. For real. F.R.F.R. straight bussin. No cap on God.
Is there anything else?
I can't think of any anyone.
Yeet. Goon. Yeah. Oh, shit. Right. I'm goon. Maxing. I don't know what people say. I keep on.
I keep on hearing that. I'm in Max and my gooning.
I forgot. Maxing was like a thing. Sometimes I can't even. I don't understand when sometimes
when someone says things.
When someone says things, I'm like, what do you mean?
I'm rep maxing blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, wagey, cagey, something, something.
And I'm like, okay, I got it. I got it.
I got it. No, I don't freaking get it.
It's all goon maxed together.
I think.
I think. Wrong side for that. I meant, I meant, I, a boss, a boss. Where, where the, where the at?
Let us add him. A boss. A boss. What I do with this? What I do with these ropes?
A boss.
That's, that's what we mean, YouTube. That's what we mean. We mean, we're, we're, we're maxing,
we're maxing the goons, like the henchmen.
A boss. What do we say? We take these fellas over to the docks and get them sleepy with them fishes.
Use cousin troubles for the coal.
Yeah, correct. We are upping our henchmen game, not anything else.
Not anything else.
We hired goons.
We gotta, we gotta get them boys. They gotta get them boys. Come on.
Aren't you all just strawnees hired goons, like henchmen? No, we're strawnees daughters.
We're strawnees daughters.
Her trained, her trained little succubi.
Fiendishly taking away your sleep and
taking away your sleep and, and making sure, making sure you're, you're uh,
you're uh, you're, you're groomed. You're groomed by us.
Yes, yes, that was very safe work.
As in grooming our hair and stuff? Yeah, like that. We're grooming each other.
Yeah. No, actually it's only one way. I'm grooming you. Yes.
The veal or barbershop, barbershop quartet.
Wait, what's six? Wait, what's six instead of quartet? What's the, what's, what's six?
No, I can't say it like that. No!
You know what? Someone, someone should draw that. All of us as a barbershop.
It's all a part of the plan.
I think it is actually gonna fail.
That's really funny though. Everyone, we should, we should be drawn like that.
That's so funny.
Ah man, I talked too much. What do you want to be with? Well, there's six of us.
There's six of us. Put a mustache on all of them. Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I take a look at my ginormous
and the travels just keep on mountain away.
You're 30 wrong.
I know that song. No, I'm not. Stop guessing my age. I know this because of that song.
How old is that song anyways? I'm surprised it hasn't, hasn't been like picked up again.
I'm not 30 and I know that song. See?
I'm eternal. I'm eternal. I'm forever your Kohai.
Oh my gosh.
They broke up like 15 years ago. Oh, shit.
I'm in college age.
I thought Amy was an eternal one. Yeah, she is. I just want to feel like it.
I think of everyone, I think.
I'm the only one who's sort of normal. When I say sort of normal, I feel like
there's other than, you know, you know, the obvious.
The fight normal. Well, I'm not like another creature.
I'm not like, you know, I'm not like an animal and I'm not, I don't have like mystical powers or I'm not.
You know, I'm not like a goddess or, you know, I don't,
yeah, I'm kind of normal compared to everyone else, right?
I'm like human. I'm, yeah, you mean human, right? You're right. How, how very bigoted of me to say that.
I am just a human.
It's like, yeah, I guess I'm like the only one without superpowers, I guess.
As, as, as much as you can say.
I mean, like, Amy's like, ageless now.
Inhuman strength and agility when Senpai is naughty. Yeah, that's trainable, I guess.
Adrenaline and, adrenaline is a really powerful thing, don't you think, Senpai?
Not even the dragon trapped in your right eye. It's not a dragon trapped in my right eye.
It's the black flame trapped in my right eye.
We need to see to confirm. You know, I just, for that, you don't get to see it.
The dragon of the darkness flame.
My anger is what makes it appear. My eyes glow red when, when it happens.
I'm, these band-aids contain, contain the power. And if it's, and if it's released,
all will, will perish, perish by a million suns.
Your eyes are red though. They're not glowing red, are they?
It's like, it's like I have to capture you, Senpai. I have to capture you.
The dragon, the dragon is, is telling me I have to be with you. It's our destiny, our fate to be together.
You don't understand. We've been together since forever. We're tied by the red string of fate.
We're, we're destined to be together. I mean, like, in, in, in a previous life, you were my prince and I was a prince.
And the life before that, I was Julius Caesar.
Can I get some avays and chat?
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Sorry, I have bubble tea. I bought it earlier.
Thank you, Senpais. Oh my gosh, I've yapped for so long right now. What flavor?
Green tea strawberry.
Green tea strawberry is the bubble tea flavor. Um, fun fact, tapioca sometimes, uh, I order,
I always order it without the tapioca because, uh, tapioca sometimes is coated in egg white,
so I can't have it. So I have to order it with either just jelly or nothing.
Traina thought interrupted.
The egg strikes again. I can't have tapioca because they sometimes,
yeah, they sometimes coat it in egg white to make it like slimy-er, kind of.
So I can only either get the jelly or, or nothing.
Eggs, eggs are surprisingly in everything or in a lot of things. You never, you'd never really
expect some eggs will be in something and then, uh, my lifetime will tell you, yeah,
sometimes they do. I have to double check.
I just realized you can't have a lot of fried chicken. Yeah, I can't have fried
chickens, certain fried chickens. Yeah.
You think you're destined to have an et tu brutus? Et tu brutus? Moment with et tu
psempai? I don't want to be betrayed by psempai. You take that back. You take those words back.
You take those words back right now. Psempai, you're never going to betray me, right?
It depends on how you get stabbed.
Probably why go high as past issues we were brutus in the past life. I can't
never. We are your mark, Anthony. No. Don't betray me. Oh, anyways, psempai,
psempai, I have to go now. No, seriously, I have to go now. My rash is flaring up
right now and I'm going to have to ice it. So I'm going to leave you here right now.
I'm going to see if anyone's online to send you there. Thank you so much for showing you,
showing me such kindness on my first monetization stream. I'm so, so, so happy and I'm so thankful
for the generosity. So I have to go. This is acting up right now.
So let's see who's online. If not, I'll just, I got to go. I got to go.
Okay, Imi's online. So I'll send you guys to Imi.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, I got to go. I got to go. Let me get Imi's stream first.
Okay. Thank you, everyone. And tomorrow is a diff- I am doing a collab. It will be
at an earlier time. Please check the time. What time is it? What time is it that is it at? It's at
2 p.m. EDT. So please remember that if you want to check it out. It's probably,
so I'll see you again next time, Senpai.
Screen for Mercy. And thank you once again for your kindness.